[Musique]
merci de regarder le journal de
l'afrique sur france 24 est heureux de
vous retrouver dans l'actualité du
continent africain aujourd'hui le kenya
attend les résultats de ces élections
générales pour la présidentielle la
course est serrée entre william ruto et
raïla odinga les deux favoris nous irons
à nairobi
après la rd congo le rwanda anthony
blinken termine sa visite en afrique
sujet inévitable le m23 qui sévit en rdc
kigali est accusé de le soutenir et puis
nous irons à agadez au niger pour les
festivités du bia nous une institution
touareg grande fête de musique et de
danse
il faudra donc encore attendre pour
savoir qui succédera à ouroux kenyatta
la tête du kenya raila odinga william
ruto sont les deux favoris la commission
électorale a jusqu'au 16 août pour
publier les résultats de l'élection une
seule certitude pour l'heure la
participation elle est en baisse par
rapport au scrutin de 2010 est à nairobi
le point avec à bastien rainews 24
heures après la fermeture des bureaux de
vote la commission électorale ne peut
toujours pas annoncé de résultat ici au
kenya et ce car la transmission des
résultats entre les bureaux de vote et
le centre national de décompte des voix
où je me trouve en ce moment à nairobi
est extrêmement complexe pour le
comprendre il faut que je vous parle des
formulaires 34 à ces formulaires ils
sont remplis par les présidents des
bureaux de vote une fois le
dépouillement terminé note les résultats
bureau par bureau dessus et prennent une
photo avec une tablette sécuriser une
tablette biométrique qui envoie ses
résultats via la 3g la 4g mobile en
direction de nairobi mais pour pouvoir
commencer à travailler au niveau
national il ya cette commission doit
aussi recevoir tous les formulaires de
manière physique je vous propose
d'écouter à ce sujet le président de la
commission électorale wafula de chez
bugatti lot de coise la loi nous oblige
à comparer les images envoyées par
internet avec les formulaires 34 à
originaux
ne pourront pas commencé le décompte des
voix tant que nous n'aurons pas
récupérer ces formulaires auprès de nos
agents qui reviennent du terrain
selon la constitution la commission a
sept jours pour annoncer le résultat
mais nous essaierons de le faire le plus
tôt possible une fois que tous nous jean
nous aurons rapporté les documents au
centre national
documents nationaux tallinn 100 la
commission électorale est extrêmement
prudente car ici tout le monde se
souvient ce qu'il s'est passé en 2017 il
y a cinq ans elle avait uniquement
utiliser les formulaires 34 à
électronique pour annoncer la victoire
12 kenyatta raila odinga avait porté
plainte devant la cour suprême qui lui
avait donné raison la commission
électorale n'avait pas bien fait son
travail l'élection avait été annulée
puis réorganiser alors cette année bien
évidemment tout le monde tient à éviter
est-ce que ce scénario se répète la
commission électorale dit qu'elle
prendra tout le temps qu'il sera
nécessaire dans la limite des sept jours
qui lui sont autorisés par la
constitution
toujours est il que les médias kényans
eux ont commencé le décompte puisque les
formulaires sont disponibles en ligne au
pour le public et pour l'instant bien la
course est extrêmement serrée entre les
deux principaux candidats william ruto
et raila odinga
c'est la dernière étape et certainement
la plus délicate de son déplacement sur
continent anthony blinken a quitté la rd
congo pour le rwanda kigali est accusé
par kinshasa de soutenir les rebelles du
m23 à l'origine de massacres dans l'est
de la rdc un soutien que semble
confirmer l'onu washington a fait part
de sa préoccupation laurent des
acheteurs
en présence de son homologue congolais
anthony blinken exprime l'inquiétude de
la maison blanche face à la montée des
tensions entre la rdc et le rwanda oui
nous sommes très préoccupés par les
informations crédibles selon lesquelles
le rwanda a soutenu le m23 nous
demandons à toutes les parties de la
région de cesser tout soutien ou toute
coopération avec le m23 ou toutes autres
groupes armés non étatiques
ancien groupe rebelle à dominante tutsie
le m23 avait été vaincu en 2013 avant de
reprendre les armes en novembre dernier
depuis il multiplie les attaques et les
exactions dans l'est de la rdc kinshasa
a longtemps accusé le rwanda de soutenir
ce groupe des accusations que semble
aujourd'hui confirmé un rapport
accablant des nations unies le document
dont des extraits avaient fuité la
semaine dernière accuse kigali d'avoir
fourni des renforts au m23 et même
d'être intervenue militairement en rdc
suite à ces révélations plusieurs ong
dont human rights watch ont appelé
washington à durcir le ton
anthony blinken devrait clairement
affirmé que les états unis imposeront
des sanctions ciblées aux responsables
gouvernementaux et aux autres personnes
qui soutiennent des groupes armés qui
commettent des abus
le secrétaire d'état américain est
arrivé mercredi à kigali dernière étape
de sa tournée africaine et s'il s'est
engagé à aborder le sujet épineux du m23
avec le président paul kagame celui ci
continue pour l'instant de nier toute
implication du rwanda avec des groupes
armés en rdc
la république démocratique du congo
justement l'est précisément à butembo
plus de 800 détenus se sont évadés de la
prison de quoi bangoura selon l'armée
deux policiers et un assaillant a été
tué dans l'attaqué à la manoeuvre les
adf les forces démocratiques alliées
elles sont accusés de commettre des
massacres dans l'est congolais des
attentats en ouganda les manifestations
contre la vie chère en sierra leone ont
dégénéré deux policiers ont été battu à
mort par la foule à freetown la capitale
le vice-président a annoncé
l'instauration d'un couvre feu
le bilan s'alourdit au mali après l
attaque menée dimanche à tes sites ce ne
sont plus 17 mai quarante deux soldats
qui ont été tuées et toujours quatre
civils décédés jamais depuis 2010 9
l'armée malienne avait payé un si lourd
tribut dans une opération attribuée à
des djihadistes un camp militaire a été
pris pour cible dans cette région des
trois frontières vous le voyez sur la
carte une zone stratégique où les
groupes terroristes s'affrontent
régulièrement
on en vient à ce paradoxe au nigeria
premier producteur de pétrole d'afrique
le pays manque de carburant il doit donc
en importer pas de kérosène des prix en
hausse conséquence certaines compagnies
aériennes doivent suspendre leurs vols
un coup dur pour un secteur en pleine
croissance reportage france 24 de moïse
comice
quelques minutes après avoir atterri à
les gosses cet aéronef à pouvoir
décoller l'équipe en charge des
opérations de nadja lines a pu trouver
du jet a1 utilisés dans l'aviation
civile ce carburant est sous tension
depuis la guerre en ukraine le nigeria
ne raffine pas son pétrole il doit donc
importer ce kérosène dont le prix a été
multiplié par trois depuis février en
raison de la pénurie de carburant bien
souvent non vols sont retardés mais nous
n'avons pas le choix nous devons à
chaque fois nous démener pour trouver du
carburant fouet
ces vingt dernières années les vols
intérieurs ont connu une forte
croissance au nigeria passant de 8 à 20
millions de voyageurs par an près une
dizaine de compagnies se disputent ce
marché local mais le coût de la
maintenance des avions plus l'explosion
du prix du carburant fragilise les
opérateurs aériens quasi tous affirment
volet actuellement à perte
il faut quand tu ne te voyons des
continuant à voler
sans valeur de chaque billet vendu aux
jambes il ne restera rien on 13 pour
vous occuper les autres aspects liés à
la sécurité des aéronefs qui sait
pourquoi de cette jungle de drogue
les classes moyennes et supérieures
nigériane reste fidèle à l'avion même si
elles voyagent de moins en moins car les
prix des billets ont augmenté en moyenne
de 70 % moins de six mois pourtant cette
passagère de ce vol les gosses abou dia
ne s'imagine pas faire le trajet en car
rapide à cause de l'insécurité routière
et des risques d'enlèvements et d'attac
tels de flight il vaut mieux prendre
l'avion pour l'instant car la rose n'est
pas sur nos moteurs donc peu importe le
christ nous nous débrouillons et nous
arrivons à payer ce n'est pas c'est un
plus mais nous l'avons toujours fait et
nous continuerons à le faire car nous
voulons tous vivre
la question de la survie se pose aussi
pour de nombreuses compagnies nigérianes
car le prix du carburant gm continue de
s'envoler sans limite
je vous emmène à présent dans nord du
niger faire un pas de côté loin du
contexte sécuritaire direction agadez
pour la fête du bia nous une tradition
la communauté touareg plusieurs jours au
rythme des chants guerriers et des
danses endiablées reportage france24
signé aaron girard
ils ont passé la nuit dans le désert du
sahara ces auditions des danseurs du
bienne qui a angulaire de la culture
bagad aise cette fête culturelle et
religieuse se prépare pendant plusieurs
semaines
les abysses et nous même qu'il est y
sont mais le tissu et la teinture que
vous voyez viennent du nigeria sur tout
le reste on le fait ici ses tenues
dépasse souvent les 500 euros
mais aujourd'hui on a des difficultés
avec les importations c'est très
compliqué depuis le nigeria à cause de
l'insécurité avant le terrorisme et
l'insécurité généralisée la fête de bia
nous attirer en dehors du continent
africain aujourd'hui elle est plus
confidentiel mais bien vivante comme
avant une bataille ici tout se prépare
jeune retraité femmes s'habillent au
rythme du tambour
midi la fête bat son plein sous les 40
degrés de l'aïr mais après la remontée
des violences au niger en 2022 quelques
angoisses subsistent nous sommes en fait
nous sommes heureux tout le monde est de
sortie tout ce que je souhaite c'est de
ne rencontrer aucun problème jusqu'à la
fin de la journée chaque défilé pendant
la fête de bienne où s'arrête devant le
palais du sultan chacun y danse à sa
manière on y célèbre la fraternité mais
aussi l'inclusion de l'autre de
l'étranger il suffit que vous aussi que
vous soyez un tribal est comme ça ou cd
classe économie on ne va pas vous
écartez
c'est ça qui renforce l'unité nationale
donc si on parle de l'unité nationale
agadez et un pivot
et c'est un symbole c'est une école à
vie
nationale seulement quelques jours de
fête et le biais nous s'évapore à
nouveau dans le sahara ayant donné ce
qu'ils pouvaient de paix dans une
atmosphère souvent troublées
c'est un pilier de la culture béninoise
le vaudou l'abbé la biennale de oued à
le mettre à l'honneur en ce moment
l'idée c'est de montrer que ce n'est pas
qu'une religion à porto novo la capitale
des adeptes font appel à des artistes
pour rénover les temples sacrés emmanuel
saez
ya trois siècles chaque communauté qui
s'installait à porto novo la capitale
politique de l'actuel bénin avait son
espace réservé une place sur laquelle
était construit des temples abritant des
divinités familiale un patrimoine
immatériel pas toujours compréhensibles
pour les non initiés
même les béninois qui ne sont pas
éduqués dans le la culture vos dons
n'arrive pas aussi apercevoir ces
différents symboles il est très
important que tous et qu'au-delà soient
mises en valeur mais ce qu'ils peuvent
mettre en valeur sont que des artistes
parce que eux ils s'approprient de
l'histoire il s'approprie des symboles
vos dons de la ville et le transcrit
avec une expression artistique
accessible
au commun dans le quartier d'hadji dans
les couvents vaudou familiaux ont été
mises en valeur par l'artiste plasticien
désir est d'aider wano le natif de porto
novo a déjà rénové une dizaine de places
là sur le mur de ce couvent il a
reproduit un balafon appelé à ceux
utilisés pour des rituels ses avis sauf
si on casse le bâtiment ces places
restaurer permettent d'attirer aussi un
public craintif à l'égard de la culture
vaudou locaux prenez par exemple et
certaines religions ils ont même peur
devenez sur les places cela permet de
valoriser la culture vaudou en faisant
transparaître sa dans des oeufs ça leur
permet de comprendre que avant l'été
c'est rien de sûr c'est convaincre les
dignitaires vaudou de réaménager des
concessions a été compliquée du fait de
leur dimension sacrée et surtout de la
diabolisation du culte ancestral
tout au début on a été confronté à des
oppositions parce que les gens issus
10ème comment peut décider du jour au
lendemain
élever les places pour d'eau alors que
pendant la période coloniale c'était des
espaces qu'ils étaient vraiment
détruite parce que on pensait que
c'était des lieux des migac satanique on
ne pouvait pas refuser nous les croyants
n'avons pas les moyens pour le faire et
si on veut nous aider c'est bien et on
peut tout le monde va en profiter
actuellement le bénin est dans un
processus de reconquête de ses trésors
matériel et immatériel en misant sur
cette industrie du patrimoine le pays
souhaite devenir une destination
culturelle et touristique majeure et
cela pourrait bien servir à démystifier
la religion au dos
le football africain fait peau neuve
dans un an tout juste une super league
africaine verra le jour annonce faite
par la caf depuis arusha en tanzanie
la première édition devrait avoir lieu
d'août 2000 23 mai 2024 concrètement 24
clubs issus de 16 pays pour gagner en
attractivité
on lui souhaite plus de succès que sa
consoeur européenne mort né en avril
merci de votre fidélité au journal de
l'afrique retrouvez nous sur france 24
points comme et nos réseaux sociaux
prenez soin de vous à demain
[Musique]